he may be ahead in the polls but joe
biden isn't taking
any chances hammering home how much is
hanging on the election
to supporters in north carolina
the very soul of the nation is at stake
folks as my coach used to say in college
it's go
time it's the most important election
in our lifetimes voter complacency could
still
derail him in a crucial week which sees
his final
tv debate with donald trump he's
painting himself
as a unifying force i'm running as a
proud democrat
but i will govern as an american
president
no red states no blue states just the
united states
[Music]
in nevada donald trump was also firing
up the base
hoping for a flood of support on
november the third
but on election day you can send a
message to the fake news media right
there
to the big tech companies
and to the washington swamp but send him
a message that they will never forget
show them that the american people are
still in charge
by delivering sleepy joe biden and the
democrats a thundering defeat on
november 3rd
and this week we'll likely see a victory
for the president
with his supreme court pick only tony
barrett
expected to be approved by the judiciary
committee
on the same day trump and biden go head
to head on tv
this is a big week for the election but
an even bigger week for the supreme
court
because a decision on the next justice
will affect people's lives for
generations
[Applause]
with just over two weeks to go both
campaigns are ramping up
trump with a deluge of rallies barack
obama
stepping up for biden as the race for
the white house
intensifies siobhan robbins
sky news washington